- So, as I mentioned earlier,
Nick and his brothers are part
of an amazing popcorn line
called Rob's Backstage Popcorn.
It tastes so good and we have
the original flavor here.
I heard y'all opening and touching it.
It was like everybody
all of the sudden was
like touching stuff and I felt like
it was like an ASMR episode or something.
- Open them up.
- [Nick] I'm gonna take some too.
- [Kelly] Everyone in
the audience has bags
so y'all try it out and I'm sorry
you're gonna get addicted to it.
So I have one here too.
- So the thing about this
flavor, this is the original.
- This is sweet and salty.
- Sweet and salty, it's the perfect
combination of sweet and salty.
- It really is.
- The brothers and I are on the back
here with Rob himself and
what's cool about this
is that, you know, it tastes delicious
and we obviously love it
'cause, you know, here we are.
But it also is, it's in that
better for you category.
- Gluten-free, so awesome.
- It's gluten-free, vegan
and it's just delicious, so.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then the fun part is now we're,
as you mentioned before, we're expanding.
- I know, you have a new flavor.
- We have a new flavor.
- Yeah.
- And we collaborated with
somebody really incredible on it.
- Just, aren't they?
They're just, they're insanely
cool, right, this person?
- I'll give a few guesses
to figure out who it is.
- Okay.
- They are a singer.
- May have been the, like,
the first ever American Idol.
- Whoa.
(audience cheering)
- But besides that has a really good
palate and understanding of taste.
- Distinguished palate.
- Distinguished palette.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And brought a lot of passion
to the creative process.
So I don't know if you guess
who this, this person is, but.
- Well, it is me, I love
this popcorn so much, but...
(audience cheering)
I was super stoked, he
texted me about it, want in?
And I was like, hell
yeah, I wanna be a part,
and hell yeah, I wanna do this.
Like, I love this popcorn so much
but I was excited to make my own flavor.
Does anyone in the audience
wanna guess what my flavor is?
- Who wants to guess, who wants to guess?
Yeah, I'm gonna go over here.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'm go over here.
Hello.
- Hi. -
- Hello.
- Hi.
- What's your name?
- My name is Kyena.
- All right, we're gonna
try this, all right.
Take a little bit there.
- All right.
- Tell me, I'm gonna try some.
Okay, okay, okay.
What do you think, what do you think?
Ooh, ooh, Is that Chipotle?
- No, mmm, I taste notes of
tuna, cardamom, no, no...
- Tuna?
- [Announcer] Stop.
(laughter)
- Old Bay, Old Bay.
- No, uh uh, stop being black, listen...
(laughter)
I think that you would, you would
invite somebody to this in your backyard.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- [Announcer] What do you think you
invited in to the backyard?
- To the back yard?
- Uh huh, with a smoker.
- Ooh, barbecue.
- That's what it is baby.
(cheering)
- That's right, it's
Kelly's Classic Barbecue,
it is so good.
(cheering)
I love that it makes you
move, it makes me move too.
It had to be spicy.
Everybody, this is it,
Kelly's Classic Barbecue.
(cheering and clapping)
(drum roll)
(cheering and clapping continues)
All right, all right, all right!
It's so good.